his report in the athletic uh where he
covers the saints he's been
uh an observer of that team for quite
some time
it was an eye-opener for us we got it
during the last commercial break we took
a look at it and we're like oh my gosh
seeing so much of what's going on behind
the scenes between the team and michael
thomas
one of the best players in the nfl and a
crucial player for the saints hopes
to win a super bowl and what we all
agree is going to be
drew brees last season we think uh jeff
duncan of the athletic here on the rich
eisen show how are you jeff
rich i'm doing good how are you doing
today i am doing fine
so let's set the stage here for
everybody
uh that uh may not know or needs a
refresher so
everybody can be up to speed here what
happened with michael thomas
uh and the saints to get him in the spot
where he didn't play on monday night
uh due to conduct detrimental as the
team said
well there was a incident at practice
rich
on saturday kind of the walk-through
portion of practice
where they're going through third down
uh game plan and
he engaged and yeah i guess it was a
fight
just let's just call it a fight i was
going to say fracas because i like that
word but
it was a fight with cj gardner johnson
and uh you know it got out of hand
basically and
michael thomas and c.j gardner johnson
were almost uncontrollable
and coaches were involved and
uh you know it got pretty ugly between
thomas and he was almost uncontrollable
from the people i talked to
and uh i think the saints tried to
handle it as best they could they wanted
to get
thomas under control and try to
reach him if you will and he was just
unconsolable at that point and
i think his actions towards the coaches
afterward is what i've been told
led to and look it's being reported
right now rich that
he wasn't suspended i think that's
semantics
he was fat they sat him for a game they
find him one game check which was 58
thousand dollars
but the the the wording suspension
is important here because that would
have opened him up to potentially losing
some guaranteed money in his contract
down the road so i think the saints
were trying to avoid that but also send
a message to thomas at the same time
that
this type of action is uncalled for and
they're just not gonna they're not gonna
stand for it well in terms of that
um your story and this is why everybody
should seek it out jeff duncan of the
athletic here on the rich eisen show
this appears to be
a i guess pugilistic tip of the iceberg
here uh let's talk about the rest of the
iceberg about what is going on with
michael thomas and this team
that you you gleaned and uh and and got
in your
report here jeff well i'll be honest
with you richard
it's no secret you know around the
saints facility
internally and externally that you know
mike thomas is
somewhat of a difficult guy to deal with
he he's a complicated personality
uh you know he's very competitive he's
one of the hardest workers on the team
very driven guy it's what's it's what's
gotten him
to where he's at in his profession as
the best receiver arguably
the best receiver in the league but
internally i mean he's
he's a difficult customer at times not
always
but i think this action that
happened over the weekend had more to do
with a
pattern of behavior that he's
uh you know displayed within the
building
that than anything else they're just
trying i think to send a message
to thomas uh that they need him
to correct some of his actions
internally it's not just
the fight on on over the weekend it was
his reaction
to the coaches who were trying to get
him
under control and and and
i guess this entire uh pattern of
behavior is what led to what we saw over
the weekend well obviously again
you know you know sean payton uh you
know him well
uh you wrote a book peyton and breeze uh
steve gleason provided the forward of
this book that you wrote the men who
built the greatest offense in nfl
history
i don't know if you saw our first blush
reaction we placed it on twitter
yesterday jeff when your report came out
we were just
bringing it all in i made a point that
this has got to be particularly bad
because sean payton comes from the
parcells world
where you don't excuse behavior but you
do treat players differently based on
how significant they
play a role in your in in your wins and
losses and how important of a player
that you are i mean
um i told a story about belichick saying
uh him going to parcells one day and
saying
uh lt was late for a meeting just want
to let you know referring to lawrence
taylor and parcells responses well why'd
you start the meeting without him
and that's where sean payton comes from
so uh this has got to be particularly
significant if sean payton is making
this maneuver and then after the game
saying uh essentially uh we'll let you
know
uh when the time's right about what the
resolution is here and when he can come
back
yeah rich that's a great point about the
parcel's influence on peyton is very
strong
and there's no doubt that this was
significant
it's what led them to make the action uh
mike thomas was going to play in this
game
on monday night against the chargers
he's the best receiver on the team he's
one of the best in the league
he's a a leader on this team this is a a
player that the saints invested
heavily in almost a hundred million
dollars last year
and when they make an investment like
that when they make a commitment mickey
loomis
sits down with the player he talks to
his representation
and says there's responsibilities that
come with this investment
when we make a commitment like this you
need to become a professional you we
expect more from you when we do this and
they've done that recently with alvin
kamara
the contract that he found recently came
with other
responsibilities rob mccamere he's much
more uh
involved now with being a spokesman for
the team
uh doing media interviews he'll be asked
to do more in the community
because of that these are the
professional things that you have to do
as a professional athlete when you
receive a commitment like that from the
organization
i think that is also playing into this
rich
with mike thomas they want him to be
more professional
uh in general and i think this was a
message sent to him
jeff duncan the athletic new orleans
columnist and again author of peyton and
brees
joining me here on the rich eisen show
all right michael thomas appears to have
commented on your article jeff
uh he sent out a series of tweets um
uh within the last 24 hours i would like
you to interpret them for me if you
don't mind
taking them all together he wrote first
up you ain't a snake
but they will make you that's first up
and then it appears to be just a few
moments later
the next tweet saying think what you
want
i ain't trying to clear no rumors up
that was
next up for him on that twitter
jaunt and then later on he retweeted
somebody asking if he's healthy please
tell me you won't be sitting out the
next game
that's either a saints man or somebody
who drafted mike thomas in the first
round of their fantasy draft uh he quote
tweeted that
and then responded i was never healthy i
was just trying to help my team get a
win
and heal up during the buy had a setback
was so close
and i take my health serious now i'm a
bad guy
l-o-l and then bats or b-e-t
uh i i don't know is he insinuating here
if you don't mind me
interpreting if you don't mind
interpreting all of them together and
i'll give you the floor in a second
is he insinuating there that he wasn't
suspended because of what happened in
terms of a fight or insubordination or
conduct detrimental that that that
they're making it seem that way and
because he's not yet
healthy i give you the floor on
interpreting all this jeff duncan
well rich i could use a uh a translator
on my social media uh attempts with
mike thomas because this isn't the first
time i've struggled to
interpret what he's trying to say here's
what i would say on that
i think clearly he's trying to avoid
losing a game check
even though it's not in relatively in
relative terms 58
dollars to all of us is a lot of money
to an nfl player it's
it's not that significant but he's
trying to hang on to that by by
using the injury as a reason
but that would be moot i think at this
point because the
team has already filed a letter of
discipline and he was going to play he
was in the
uh you know game plan for the game so
this
this transgression was related uh
to the incident that was involved not he
wasn't fat because of
his health and i think he's trying to
present that case probably
through his representation in that
regard but i would say this rich and i
think it's important to say this
mike thomas has tried to play the last
two or three weeks he's a tough
customer and he wanted to get on the
field and the team
did the right thing by sitting and they
want to be cautious that's a finicky
injury a
high ankle sprain they had mike thomas
talk to dr
anderson the leading ankle uh
doctor in the country to explain to him
why it's important for him
to be uh you know cautious with this
injury it could
it could sideline him for the rest of
the year but he was trying to come back
sooner that's the competitive desire and
the competitiveness of mike thomas and
it's one of the reasons he's
such a great player jeff duncan a few
more minutes left with the athletic new
orleans columnist and reporter here on
the rich eisen show
now then uh this is not our first rodeo
um
in a story like this one jeff and this
is not yours either i'm sure
why do you know this stuff as we try to
move this towards
how does this all get resolved if at all
why is this
out there isn't this supposed to be
in-house stuff and by the way i'm very
appreciative of your reporting
uh but do we read into the fact that you
know this
that you're reporting it that it's been
it's gotten to somebody with
a keyboard and a platform should we read
into that
no i i don't think so look i i think you
know we don't in this world we're in
right now
24 7 coverage especially the nfl these
things tend to take
on a life of their own on social media
i think the saints are going to handle
this just fine they have
strong leadership in the locker room i
talked to drew brees about it after the
game monday
all the team leaders on this team have
already talked to mike thomas
uh sean payton you know him rich i mean
he's going to handle this thing they
already have
handled it i don't think it's going to
blossom into anything more
than what it has already i think we've
seen the tip of the iceberg and it's
going to go the other way
i really believe that um
that the strength of this team is going
to ward off any blossoming
or mushrooming problem with mike thomas
and this was just a case of
we don't want it to become an antonio
brown situation or
something that's going to uh you know be
bigger down the road
we want to head this off at the pass if
you will and this is
a great player with a great career in
front of him
the team has made a huge investment and
they don't want to see this
continue to spiral the wrong way
and i think it could on another team but
not with this team with the veteran
leadership
and the coaching staff that's intact
here no i guess that's
that's the you you touched upon my last
question for you jeff because you're
seeing
all the comparisons where you know mike
tomlin won a super bowl
uh ben roethlisberger is a first ballot
hall of famer um
sean payton's won a super bowl and a
very strong willed uh
brilliant head coach drew brees the
first ballot hall of famer
saints are an organization that's not in
flux steelers are never an organization
that's in flux and we saw what antonio
brown did
now i guess mike thomas is not you know
facebook living out uh
sean payton calling bruce aryan's names
you know but
uh how similar is this is this something
similar you're already seeing the
comparisons le'veon bell's been released
here
um you know mike thomas better than we
do uh we have had him on the show he
couldn't have been more professional and
open
uh even though i'm a michigan man and he
probably despises me just for that alone
but um you know seriously like is is
there any there there
to these comparisons that you're already
seeing
no i think it's premature but
i think it could get there if it's not
addressed and
you know sean payton uses a phrase a lot
that he learned from
bill parcells about tending the garden
you know that coaching
and managing a locker room is like
gardening you've got to do it every day
if you don't
it gets out of hand and that's what sean
payton's doing here
he's gardening i mean he's making sure
this does not get out of hand
down the road he's addressing it head on
and i know you're right different
players get treated differently
but sean payton believes in culture he's
big time into that
and he thinks they've got an excellent
locker room and he's right it's one of
the best i've ever covered
they're trying to prevent this from
becoming an issue
a greater issue for this team down the
road especially for a team that has
super bowl aspirations and expectations
players on the team have already said
this is a
super bowl or bus season it could be
drew brees as last year
and i think sean payton's just trying to
handle this situation before it
potentially could mushroom into
something bigger i hear you but these
three tweets say
this is not particularly buttoned up
just yet but we'll see
uh post bye week crystal ball it for me
jeff duncan
is uh mike thomas suited up ready to go
against carolina is he out there
well i think we'll know more after today
if he addressed the team
at the team uh meeting this morning and
apologized which i was told is something
he was gonna do
uh i think it'll be behind him and he'll
be back in the lineup right away
i'll be surprised if he's not jeff
thanks for the uh
the call uh again uh congrats on your
book peyton and breeze uh jeff dunk by
jeff duncan ford by steve gleason who is
an amazing human
um and uh and this reporting it was
eye-opening and uh i look forward to
getting you back on to revisit if it's
necessary
anytime rich thanks for having me that's
jeff duncan at jeff duncan underscore
if you want to follow him on twitter
what a story